josh duhamel he has Duke Michigan
Wisconsin in the Final Four North
Carolina Duke winning over North
Carolina and the championship game where
are you right now Josh in the good many
reserves in the Serengeti National Park
in Tanzania are you shooting a movie in
Tanzania no I'm not here with an
organization called Africans the
opportunity African Community
Conservation Foundation doing all kinds
of sort of anti poaching stuff and
that's a community outreach staff girl
empowerment stuff it's been the most
unbelievable trip ever been on
Shirley and I want to thank you for the
video that percentage you did the videos
that you sent me yesterday yeah yeah so
did America I let everybody see that
video yesterday on the show you a little
bit I know who shot that video it's kind
of sad but you did add the steamy josh
duhamel look though in the shower and I
appreciated that soda today yeah I
thought I heard somebody in the
background but it could have been
animals there I have no idea but leopard
had pulled the warthog up in the tree
and eating it I've seen about a million
giraffes I've seen a million elephants
see the lines we just got done coming
back to this little village and saw like
12 line your eyes
they're trees I felt like I just killed
a cape buffalo the day before Wow
it's been unbelievable I mean truly
unbelievable it is it scary to a Gardens
Safari game run but you go on yeah or
not I mean at the bitter for years so
they go right you're fighting for life
are you sure are you able to watch the
tournament in Tanzania no Duke I'm sure
no that's tonight
McLovin would you really would you recap
to Josh Duhamel joining us from Tanzania
what happened yesterday
where where does he stand in the bracket
oh no he's right in the middle with
everyone he got 12 right I don't have in
front of me which ones he got wrong but
he went kind of chalky I recall okay all
right so you're hanging in there no not
really Wofford beat Seton Hall yet a
couple of Murray State beat Marquette I
guess I guess those those that would be
considered up says do they know you in
Tanzania they haven't seen haven't seen
transformers
it's a giant dose of perspective is what
it is is because obviously we come out
here my intention was he you know raise
awareness about anti poaching of rhinos
and elephants and all that but this
organization advocacy CF is about not
only conserving and protecting these
these beautiful creatures but also
finding a way to create harmony between
the villages that brought that up
against this the Serengeti
because the elephant's going can trample
the crops up before harvest like you
know it's because their income for the
year there's a big there's a big what
they call animal or human wildlife
conflict here then I didn't know
anything about until I got here and so
we got to go into some of these villages
and see and neither are these people and
they're just companies are amazing
people I'm not kidding they're just so
full of life it's really really been
funded witness maybe send another video
I will it's up to you you know whatever
expresses you I know that the director
on this show at DirecTV appreciated
yesterday's video so I think she was
ready to retire after the show but uh
just just throwing it out there you know
you can she's like oh really married you
saw on the air relationship on the air
and relationship off the air down and
that's just sort of reached everything
well you got to let me know it's like
when somebody tell an athlete tells me
it's off the record then it's off the
record and if you said hey for your
private use only Dan I'm sending you
this shower video that's on you well be
safe over there we'll keep you updated
on your brackets always great to hear
from you Duke Michigan Wisconsin North
Carolina Duke over North Carolina I mean
you got a couple of interesting calls
there but you still have Duke over North
Carolina and a lot of people are gonna
have that so you know it almost feels
like you have to take something
different yeah I want to see this entire
Williamson it's just unbelievable I
don't think in college basketball no yes
yes McLovin well yeah josh is the only
wisconsin in the final
for in fact as many people have Oregon
beating Wisconsin today at 4:30 is have
them advance ooh
so you're the you're the Wisconsin loner
on the tournament Wisconsin yeah all
right well you might get your bracket
might get stung a little bit there later
on today but you want to know about it
or would you rather just wait till you
get back home okay
all right all right we will keep the
cards and letters coming Thank You Josh
that's Josh Duhamel the actor
transformers life as we know it
Las Vegas the pride of Minot North
Dakota that's interesting you know the
video he sent he sent me another video
where he was showing me the wildlife
there yesterday look unbelievable if you
missed any of our interviews this week
from the mercedes-amg man cave go to the
Dan Patrick show app where you can watch
and listen from inside the mercedes-amg
man cave mercedes-amg
driving performance for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
ass
[Music]